it's been six months since joe biden
became president which means six months
of the immediate kiss in his
butt terrible language and six months of
hyperbolic
divisive and truly bizarre moments the
hill points out biden's mouth has been
getting him into trouble especially when
he goes off scripts
with scripts with comments like these
the last thing we need is neanderthal
thinking that in the meantime
everything's fine
the only pandemic we have is among the
unvaccinated
and that's and they're killing people i
got them
1.9 trillion dollars relief so far
21st century jim crow assault is real
what do you do so when did i say i was
confident the economy was sputtering
before i got here
but now six months later we've changed
that to be a good reporter you got to be
negative you got to have a negative view
of life okay it seems to me
i wrote the bill on the environment
you know katie this stuff doesn't really
bother me that much you know he's almost
90. uh so it's okay the thing that bugs
me about it
is that is he failing to unify this
country or was that a lie to begin with
the whole idea of unification
i'm pretty sure that was just a campaign
slogan
like many politicians there's been no
unifying especially when
over the past couple of weeks where
they're saying that these voter id laws
which the vast majority of the country
supports are the same thing as
jim crow 2.0 uh he exaggerates about a
lot of that he's accused facebook of
killing people which they're obviously
not doing
uh i think it's funny to laugh at that
but it's also troubling because he keeps
telling everybody that
you know he'll get in trouble if he
takes certain questions from the press
which makes you question who's really in
charge
and there's just factors with the way
the country is going inflation's through
the roof
crime has increased violent crimes
increased around the country the border
is completely overrun
cova cases are going back up again and
russia has a pipeline and keystone is
dead so
not a great six months yeah you know
unity yeah
and you know jesse we spent four years
being told how divisive
trump was but i st he
trump said anything and everything but
he was always focused on the media and
the political machinery
whereas it seems to me like president
biden goes after
those people who didn't vote for him
republicans or
groups of people and i think there's a
difference there the device that's truly
divisive
there's i didn't think there was any
advice about trump going after the media
but yeah we expected that and it's very
entertaining to watch but
all the language so far from joe has
been sloppy uninspiring
and wrong i mean he's had some real
pinocchios
facebook is killing people had to walk
that back i mean
facebook's got to be thinking joe we had
a deal here we covered up your hunter
biden problem
we covered up the lab leak theory we
donated to your campaign you're going to
call us killers
so joe spoke to his handlers and
realized that donations were going to
dry up and he had to walk that back also
what happened to the infrastructure
bipartisan deal that he announced weeks
ago about to die he had to walk that
back that never happened
so a lot of this stuff i mean is just so
fact checkable but the media doesn't do
anything about it the media and his
people
know joe has bad instincts and a sloppy
mouth and they'll do anything to protect
joe from himself so that's why he's not
allowed to talk to anybody and engage
with the media and it makes the rest of
the country feel like hey
this country feels leaderless right now
and not responsive
to growing crisis at the border at the
gas pump
and it's not a good feeling you know uh
harold i'm
always troubled by the hyperbolic nature
of this white house
but having said that would you say that
joe biden is the worst
leader since genghis khan
[Laughter]
so i have a slightly different view
if you look at some of the numbers here
he's six months in his approval rating
is at 53 percent including according to
the most reuters
most recent reuters poll he's 52 with
independence
six months into president trump's who's
the most recent president office he was
at 38
i think a strong argument can be made
around three positives one
the vaccinations are available two the
economy uh
is roaring again uh it roared a lot
under president trump without question
but it's roaring again
three we've unified our allies again
particularly in europe
and we're finding ways i think
commercial resources to go after china
we've said at this table and i'll be
brief here crime and immigration i would
agree if he does not if democrats are
perceived
as being the problem with these two
issues rising and worsening
this certainly puts the rest of the
agenda at risk
on the infrastructure piece it's
reported today that that there was a
blow to
senator schumer and democrats in the
senate but the negotiators continue to
work
if we get a good uh one trillion dollar
bill and it's amazing the chinese are
spending trillions under military and
all kinds of technology advances and
we're debating a trillion dollar
infrastructure bill uh i gotta think the
chinese are sitting back laughing at us
so
he's got to make crime and immigration
and infrastructure
make progress there those numbers will
continue to go up but i got to tell you
if i was president i had a 53 approval
rating i feel pretty good
you can take four points off that
approval rating we already had the after
action report on the fake polling that
came out
take four points off or four points so
he's underwater
under 50. and he hasn't brought our
allies together he's pushed our allies
to russia
yeah i differ i think i think uh i i'm
more concerned about
their obsession with wokism is is is
actually keeping them from these
these questions on immigration and and
on crime but
the other thing about the democratic
party and the left in general is
they invented the concept of hate speech
right and yet
the stuff that they traffic in is so
incendiary right it's like you know
worst thing since the civil war worst
thing since 9 11. everything's the worst
thing since
the worst thing that's kind of hate
speech right because
it is hate speech but it's tolerated by
their ilk
it's tolerated it's a one-way street
right they don't
they don't care listen joe bide this is
a two-year sprint to the midterms
they're going to push through with no
mandate
50-50 split in the senate uh the
narrowest of margins of the house they
are going to push through an expansion
of government
and entitlement after entitlement after
entitlement
that will rival or even swamp fdr
in 33 that will rival or swamp lbj
in 1965. that's what's so appalling
i but i want to end with by i kind of
like the east woody and biden when he's
reading a teleprompter like he's
squinting it makes him look
tougher than the wide-eyed biden where
he looks like grandpa
lost in the walmart and he's like
walking up and down the feminine hygiene
aisle
it's always been my excuse hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else